but he's going on YouTube today is a day
of Howie aka Halloween
are y'all ready a lot of people have it
asked me what are my thoughts on
Halloween um what can I say besides
today with pedophiles come out hi kids
hi to Mike because ghetto [ __ ]
coming out tonight there's something I
like to call Halloween etiquette that's
a way to celebrate it in a way not to so
for all of you dumbasses out there let
me help you out with this one LG acid
get it now there are some of you out
there that don't realize you're too old
to go trick-or-treating and not so much
celebrating Halloween because everybody
loves Halloween it's great you get the
dress-up you're not living off the
talent if you get rejected bitch'll cave
is Halloween
nobody will know what you really look
like so you could basically you know say
whatever you want excuse me trick Oh
trick baby give me something good to
have a baby
uh no thanks uh well obviously you dress
up as a [ __ ] what you're allowed to
you are not allowed to do on Halloween
depends on your age if you are over the
age of 21 and you dress up as a power
ranger then with something seriously
wrong with your ass yes might as well
come to sound as Hsss package babies
your mind you thought you dressed up at
the green pound when you did it yeah but
in reality you just dressed up as a
pedophile in Greek spandex after a
certain age you should stop offering
candy to children in public once again
in your mind
this is probably what you think you look
like oh hey kids I'm sure some extra
candy you want some of mine but back to
reality this is what the perverted ass
probably looks like
feathered he almost Academy I got some
in my basement no no no ghetto people I
understand that you love Halloween I'm
getting I get it it's probably the only
day I'll be able you get to go to a nice
house and get free stuff without having
to break into it but ghetto ask people
here's a little tip if you're going
trick-or-treating and you already have
kids [ __ ] you too old how are
you gonna go home it stopped raining
candy but your baby's okay if you
mustnít over that payday though Daniel I
want to I bet you're trading all what
that [ __ ]
I know people growing up is a hard thing
to do but you got to realize after a
certain age
things aren't acceptable when you're a
child your fly's open that [ __ ] is
hilarious you're an adult then your
fly's open
that's an open invitation for something
else sagging your pants make you seen
ghetto afterwards certain age but at the
age of 50 it just makes you seem like
the old ass forgot how to dress yourself
so remember people when you're out there
on Halloween and having a good time
remember just to act appropriate there's
a certain amount of self awareness of
all I'm self aware down but I found the
hard way I used to think that I was the
best at this game called hide and go
seek as a child that I found out that
people just they were looking for me if
later on tonight I asked you to be my
girlfriend right
YouTube will be warned about costume
sizes because if you don't you might end
up with the man's gun it's a mammal toe